[Musique]
ah me voilà agien dans le Loiret pour
rencontrer le Père Paul benésit qui a
remporté une compétition divine le
championnat de France cycliste du
clerger autant vous dire qu'il met un
coup de frais au monde
ecclésiastique et durant ces balades en
vélo le pière Paul a même le temps de
réfléchir de prier de brasser et de
jouer de la guitare vous l'avez compris
le pière Paul un prêtre au multiple
talent ah bah justement le voilà alors
Pierre
Paul rattraper pire Paul
[Musique]
ou ah rapide hein père Paul hein oui en
pour toi ton histoire elle est
incroyable on va commencer par le côté
religieux comment tu es devenu prêtre le
coup de foudre avec le bon Dieu moi à
l'âge de 15 ans c'éit coup de foudre
avec SAR
vitran je me suis fait larguer à la
deuxème récréation le mardi après la
rentrée scolaire j'ai très mal vécu j'ai
toujours vraiment adorer partager ma foi
parler de Dieu rencontrer des croyants
d'autres religions rencontrer des non
croyants parce que moi ma foi me donne
de la joie elle donne un sens à ma vie
et elle me donne une espérance on va
parler de ta rencontre avec le sport à
16 ans j'ai fait mon premier triathlon
et c'est en faisant du triathlon que
j'ai j'ai découvert le vélo redécouvert
parce que enfant j'adorais faire du VTT
dans les bois mais là je suis passé au
vélo de route et voilà la passion est
arrivée bon ben écoute je vais essayer
de te suivre et tu m'amènes au presbyère
c'est comme ça qu'on dit le presbyère
allez la maison des prêtres direction le
presbyèire la maison des prêtres on va
parler guitare on va parler bière aussi
parce
que
un truc que je voulais savoir c'est
commencé est-ce que tu fais de la
guitare en
[Musique]
véloconomiste souffleamini on parler
làhaut pres bout fait une heure que tu
dis qu'on est presque arrivé oh là mal
jambes on dirait un peu en prier
Paul comment tu fais ça de Ten comme
çaroable
miracleoch en même temps le bouton pour
la cloche c'est
ce waouh quelle vue mais alors pourquoi
gen justement PR est venu exercer ici on
dit exercer aussi pour les prêtres comme
les médecins ou pas oui on peut dire
exercer son ministère agien parce que
l'évêque mis à nommé comme Jésus a
envoyé ses ses apôtres l'évêque envoie
ses prêtres dans le département pour
remplir leur mission tu brasses aussi de
la bière comme les anciens comme les
moines j'ai brassé de la bière pour
faire venir les gens à la messe pour la
première édition du pèlerinage on a
offert la bière et on a eu cinq fois
plus de de paroissien que d'habitude
voilà voilà l'Église doit se moderniser
et elle est en cours de modernisation et
dans ce cours de modernisation je vois
une guitare là-bas c'est un des talents
que j'ai développé assez tardivement par
rapport au sport je me suis mis à 20 ans
pour l'église pour chanter jouer à
l'église ah bah c'est parfait bah on va
chanter ensemble vas-y et ben c'est
parfait parce que père Paul c'est il est
quand même de la famille de Chun Paul en
musique t'inquiète j'ai rencontré le
père Paul j'ai plus de genoux j'ai plus
d'épaules ça c'est pas faire du vélo
Paul non non toi tu voles et j'ai pu
profiter de gens la vue belle on se sent
bien et ça me donne envie de chanter
[Musique]
alléluia
alléluiaia